let me first give a disclaimer legal if
you know a disclaimer to class and also
to you internet pay attention um which
is that I'm going to do I'm going to try
to explain this like Han all of the
things I've had to they're all publicly
available that's actually most of how I
know this stuff right so Board of
Studies are they've got like a big guy
on how my HSC marks are calculated um
most of which is where I've been is from
and are you a Caswell University of
mission center because they're the guys
who decide the eight are okay they also
publish all of this okay so I'm not this
is not like kind of super secret
knowledge that I'm sharing with you it's
all there it's just that it is it is
quite complicated
um and what's half of it I'm saying took
a while like reading it all so that's
the first thing it's all publicly
available and secondly because it is
actually really complicated I'm not
going to explain all the details it
would literally take me days if I went
through everything and I know that
because it took me days to read it and
process it and try and understand it so
I'm just going to try and give you like
an overview like a simplified version
I'm going to sort of skirt over a lot of
the finer details but I think you'll
still get the basic idea
okay so here's here's basically is
there's kind of three problems that
explain why you do your agency you get
some marks right but they have to do all
this weird stuff to your marks and
adjust it and muck around with it before
you get your your final thing okay and
the three polls they're all problems of
comparison okay so the first problem is
try to compare schools okay so how do we
fairly compare schools when the schools
obviously are different they're
different in lots of ways
okay the second problem is about trying
to compare one cohort from another okay
so you're the 2013 cohort well how do
you compare with the 2012 cohort or the
2014 cohort that comes after you okay
and lastly it's about comparing
yes okay because all subjects are
difficult in different ways and they're
difficult to different levels so how do
you fairly compare them okay so they're
problems of comparison so to try and put
this in like concrete terms okay I want
you to picture another and see how
there's a problem right if you get 95 in
one school right
what does that 95 mean what does it
James ruse 95 mean versus a 95 from some
other school from another state or all
those kinds of things right magnifies
mean different things because you know
the kinds of assessments that you do are
just different you know some schools out
there they don't do trial exams can
anyone think of why why don't they do
trial exert are you two reasons students
hate doing charlie exams and teachers
hate writing and March in Charlie's in
it's a little work okay we still done
they don't know why because it's just
the best way to prepare to actually you
know rehearse it just as if you were
going to do the real thing three hours
all the same topics and so on right but
if some schools do trials
and some don't how can the 95 be the
same right or in IPT I have this massive
amount of flexibility about the actual
kinds of assessments and projects I give
my class right and a lot of subjects are
like that I do to an oral assessment if
you do a visual rebel or whatever okay
so 95 one school and 95 another totally
different in the same way this year if
you guys get 95 right um how can you
compare that to a 95 from last year what
if write your exam turns out to be a
killer it's terrible right and you guys
get 95 you know Jonathan saying or
something but blood sweat and tears he
scores that whereas maybe last year or
next year the exams just a breeze and
like half of you get 95 well how can you
compare the two 95 and you see where I'm
going here right so 95 in maths
one versus 95 in tuna maths
well actually wouldn't be 95 from SSN
2047 I guess because out of 50 okay but
clearly those magnifiers are different
right and you can multiply across
different subject
right so how did I deal with this
problem they do three things for three
problems okay for the first two they're
dealt with by the border sighs okay
they've got two processes the first one
to deal with the difference between
schools they call it moderation so they
are they moderate the mark that's what
they call it and to deal with the
differences between years the cohorts
they have a process is called alignment
the last problem the problems that that
parent subjects right that's not dealt
with by the Board of Studies because all
they're interested in is getting the
marks right for every individual subject
okay this problem because it's really a
problem about considering multiple
subjects together and coming up with
before an eight art you get something
called an aggregate so you guys know
about that so it's 500 bucks it's your
10 best units so this is dealt with by
uaq okay and the process this is where
this is what most people think of as the
process they call this scaling
okay now one more word for you sometimes
these two processes because they're done
number one by the same group of people
and number two they're done together
so even though number one moderating
happens and then number two alignment
have happens you never see what happens
in between here the school doesn't see
we don't find that out we just get the
mark after two moderated and aligned
okay so often those two processes are
called one
they're called more mapping very sickly
so they get the marks get mapped by
water study and then you act scales the
recording okay